i if you hadn't already caught up right
well to keep the jobs that are both
created or destroyed or pushed back by
this new or new industry right actually
by the way if you want to make a proper
heading for this you can call it more
than multimedia jobs maybe a better way
to say would be expertise that is
required it's really about skill every
expertise required by the multimedia
industry all right now before I start
off with a few I you guys just saw a
whole bunch right so help me out where
would you start
or is the first most obvious one we
looked at the the Foley artist right now
this is ingenious the idea is that how
is this connected you guys know exactly
the right categories to think through
this right what data I requires this
which multimedia type rather surprising
audio yeah and I think we are because
we're not looking at it we're not so
conscious about how much work goes into
creating the audio that we enjoy in a
movie right
not just the Foley artist by the way say
something like the voices that you hear
when you're watching a movie okay then
the voices aren't created by the Foley
artist that has to be created by the
actors themselves so they know what's
the name of the person whose job it is
to make sure they capture that audio hey
have you ever seen yeah it's it's about
the microphone right so much like here
how we've got a separate mic okay if
you're out in a windy environment you
can't just use the microphone that's on
the camera okay you've got to have a
separate one and it's held out a really
long stick it's called a broom right
it's a long stick with a mic angle
the end of it right so you got what you
got a boom handler and it's their job to
always be in the right place at the
right time and to capture everything and
to not get in the frame which is hard
about it sounds right
okay so audio that multimedia type is
requiring these kinds of people all
right and then we went and looked in the
next video
about visuals and they distinguish
between this idea of the old way which
we call motion capture what did um what
did James Cameron call it
he was distinguishing this way using
called motion capture he called it
performance capture what do you get as
this distinction between these two
performance versus motion
what do you think
this is gonna be a really long video you
take it do you remember what he was
trying to get is that the actors
emotions right everything on their faces
is being captured and they had to design
this camera that would come around I
would like the face and you would get
everything that he actions are actually
doing facially right that's a little bit
different to say if you remember a lot
of the Rings right when that came out
one of the big deals particularly which
maybe was it was the second or the third
he was the second but there was a big it
was a major character introduced who was
completely computer-generated right and
his name was going on right now by the
way why was he completely
computer-generated yeah because when you
think about what the character looks
like what the multimedia demands of it
right to try and thwart a real human
being into that would be deeply
unsettling and deeply unsatisfying right
so that was motion capture employed
there okay the way he crawled around and
moved was captured by a series of you
know special markers on a special suit
right and therefore you've got people
involved who this right so you've got
what we call motion capture actors not
just regular actors motion capture
actors right and nowadays basically
every big-budget video game also has
motion capture actors associated with it
right quite separate for the people core
voice actors yeah so you've got a whole
new area of employment that's been
created by this technology motion
captures quite news right 20 years ago
you didn't have motion capture or
performance capture okay and then we
move on to a few general videos now
apart from these ones what rolls jumped
out to you that are part of the
multimedia industry
in a mystery Tama video they'll fix you
order all of the three or four guys
where a particular kind of role yeah
like a good special effects so so much
of what we see these days has been
altered right actually I reckon it
wouldn't be an exaggeration to say
everything we see is altered in some way
even if it's not you know explosions and
you know tolerating and all that kind of
thing
everything's been altered from what was
actually taken off the video yeah so
special effects are people like enemies
you know when you're watching those
videos and there are people talking but
it's not like this is not just one
continuous stream of talking the the
blank spots between people's sentences
have been cut out right now that's not
automatic there's got to be a person who
does them right okay no that was a whole
bunch of the ones that we saw in the
videos let's go through a few extra
different ones that didn't come up there
okay have you ever been looking at a
website or magazine and there's like
photos illustrating things right but
it's all really standard people like it
was a specifically caption for this
website or this company that that kind
of picture has a name is in other words
called yeah that's right stock
photography now do you see how this is
connected to that question this is all
about the image multimedia time right
and the people want to get high-quality
professional-looking imagery right they
want professional content provided to
them but they don't have the resources
on the in their own company to get it
right they don't have the nice flashy
cameras or the good-looking models or
the the right lighting setup all that
kind of thing so there are companies
devoted to providing these kinds of
services okay
all right what else have we got I think
about will you be watching a movie right
and things like say we were the rings or
even something like say Monsters Inc
right you've got these special effects
but more specifically you've got people
who will call animators right now do you
remember we're looking at cel animation
before a person who was an animated
before were supposedly drew things out
by hand
right but now it's a little bit
different what do they specialize in
what kind of skills do they have yeah
it's gonna be about computer graphics
right so things like 3d modeling
creating say um
textures texture artists if there isn't
a lot of rings there were massive cities
that were created that weren't real they
were all actually created by animators
right but you want this is not realistic
you want it to Brick's to look like
bricks so you've got to have people
create them okay now actually I'll add
on top of this I talked about Monsters
Inc I said this is an interesting movie
who are the two main characters in what
Susie
there's not really a mainecat well I
suppose she is sort all but she's not
the focus of the story
really she's longer the dramas about
it's about the green dude come on do it
Mike Wazowski okay the green dude with
one eye Mike Wazowski and there was
Sulley the big hairy guy okay here's the
theme right Sulley okay
he's interesting as an animated
character because he's very different
from previous characters because he was
covered in well okay now just have a
look at him for a second think about the
challenge that he poses to an animator
right only think about that all the
characters the same it's not true right
because he's covered in fur how many how
many hairs do you think he has or how
many hands do you have on your head like
hundreds of thousands right so we can't
traditionally take you know a 3d model
and model every single hair you'd be
there for you know years right so what
did they do what they did was they
created software that would one simulate
actually all of his hands by the way
they're not they're not uniform they're
not equal because if they were one we're
very realistic right as realistic as a
what's the nose right ah one look
realistic lifelike in the same way when
he moves around okay the hairs don't
just stay still they're not static right
they're dynamic they have to move in
accordance to wind and all that kind of
thing right how did they do that they
didn't just use 3d models and really
nice textures right they had to design
software specifically to handle his hair
okay so there's only sophisticated roles
and skills behind what we see that makes
it all possible
okay on top of this you've got general
things like say managers we looked for a
long time why would a project manager be
required for a multimedia production
what is why the project manager required
on any large project okay sounds money
he has to managed if you don't have a
project manager you're going to use too
much time and too much money and it's
just gonna be really inefficient and the
multimedia industry just like any is
built on very fine you know money
everything's expensive right okay so
that's a it's a long set of different
roles you can you go into more detail
under each one right so texture artist
there'll be specific ones who make
synthetic textures they've been created
made up versus people who are aimed at
mimicking natural textures right like I
talked down bricks in that terrific okay
but that's a set of the different kinds
all expertise is required now what I
want you guys to do in your own past
trip was that kind of thing
it's think about if this is the positive
side this is what's been created anew
what's the negative side the the
existence of this industry has pushed
back other jobs and other roles and made
them less significant we talked about
the Industrial Revolution right and how
you had new people to build factories
and build machines and work the machines
new jobs but you also had jobs destroyed
or at least made much smaller than they
were before so all the tailor's who made
clothing and shoes by hand if you
couldn't make a living out of that
anymore in the scale that you used to be
able to so I'd like you to think about
five existing jobs just five that have
receded or being made redundant and
unnecessary useless by the multimedia
industry okay